hello good morning after a bruising week
at the dispatch and ballot boxes the
pressure on the prime minister's
mounting once again
simon case the country's top civil
servant and the man charged with leading
the investigation into alleged christmas
parties at downing street has been
forced to step aside now it's because it
was revealed that he himself was aware
of a separate party in his own office a
year ago
and if the fallout was not pressure
enough for boris johnson while he's now
weighing up options to curb record
numbers of covert 19 cases
he'll call an emergency cobra meeting
this weekend with lockdown measures
reportedly on the table our political
correspondent jay pike has this
morning's first report
he's off the case the uk's top civil
servant no longer investigating
christmas parties because he was at one
boris johnson has set the tone for his
government and he lives by one rule for
him and another rule for everyone else
and i think
you know people can see through that now
and it's incredibly hard to believe that
no one in government knew that these
parties were happening it's about the
behavior of the prime minister about the
stuffing of cronies into the house of
lords over the scandal that was seen
over the renovation of the flat and
downing street for his misled parliament
um quite frankly this is behavior which
is unacceptable
and it is time that he went and he
should be taking his cabinet secretary
with him
the woman now in charge is sue gray a
formidable former government ethics
chief
the partygate scandal is growing by the
day as is the civil service
investigation into what happened and
when but under sue gray it could be
highly dangerous for boris johnson and
his team she is fearsome
independent-minded pulls no punches and
has ended ministerial careers her report
when it comes may draw a line under this
whole saga but some in downing street
could end up as collateral damage
the eyes to the right 369
the nose to the left 126.
so the eyes have it the eye after a week
of parliamentary rebellions
covid concerns
[Applause]
and by election batterings boris johnson
knows the buck stops with him i'm
responsible for everything that the
government does and of course i take a
personal
responsibility some tory mps say he
needs to change we'll soon find out if
that's even possible joe pike's sky news
westminster
well onto coronavirus now and after
record cases were recorded for a third
straight day there are reports that
further restrictions are being
considered including plans for a
possible two-week circuit breaker
lockdown after christmas
the government says it will keep
measures under review as it learns more
about the omicron variant
its continuing efforts to ramp up the
booster campaign with stadium and race
courses transformed into vaccination
centers as ali forzaki reports
this was a week before christmas last
year and we've come a long way since
then
the streets are busier there is some
christmas cheer
but hanging heavy uncertainty over
omicron
we're not overly comfortable it's more
crowded here than it has been but we've
been pleased for our sake that it's not
been very busy if you know what i mean
we're hard at work and we haven't had
very much chance to soak up some
christmas spirits those christmas
atmosphere so we're just having
a a day out and just being careful about
it
but as people prioritize businesses need
help
you run a restaurant on one of the
busiest streets of the world one of the
busiest times of year how is business
not great to begin with um
[Music]
it's there but not what it's supposed to
be at this time
of the year
london is the epicenter of the outbreak
in this country more than 60 of cases
here now are omicron and it's overtaken
delta as a dominant strain and while
it's by no means empty here it is not as
busy as it should be this time of year
because lots of people are making their
own minds up looking at the data and
deciding to stay at home
and where matches have been cancelled
stadiums are being transformed wembley
and filled in stamford bridge among the
places stepping up this weekend to
deliver boosters
i think the boosting program will
definitely help but i think at this
point in time when you have cases of a
new variant that are doubling in less
than two days nothing
um
that depends on vaccination is going to
be fast enough simply because somebody
who's getting vaccinated today it'll
take between one to two weeks for them
to develop that level of protection and
in that period of time you expect
perhaps you know three to seven
doublings already to have occurred
preliminary studies are optimistic about
boosters and omicron but as cases surge
across europe navigating a route through
this will matter well beyond christmas
ali forskou sky news
well our correspondent studia chaudhry
is at the charleston athletic football
ground in southeast london and joins us
now good morning to you saudia so the
booster race is on
good morning vanessa yes do you remember
earlier in the week when the nhs
england's uh medical director for
primary care doctor nikki kanani said
that football fans should go to a
stadium to get their boosters this
weekend well this is it this is charlton
athletics football ground being
converted into a mass vaccination center
again they did so earlier in the year
but it's happening again here which
means that fans not just of charlton
athletic of course anyone can come in
here to get their vaccines it opens at
eight o'clock this morning it's walk-ins
but as well as that it's also people
that can
book their appointments using the nhs
booking
service and it's going to run today and
tomorrow it's not just at this site
there are football grounds across the
country that are also
doing this
and it comes as as part of this big push
to offer everyone a booster vaccine
we've got old trafford in manchester
who's also running clinics like this uh
the wembley stadium is being used in
addition there are going to be 750
personnel from the armed forces and
thousands of volunteers all taking part
in this drive to get
boosters into people's arms and it comes
of course as covered cases
are rising we know that the premier
league is being affected there are only
five fixtures this weekend two of them
today and it comes as clubs are
reporting coveted outbreaks amongst
their team and their staff
coaching staff trading ground staff
which is why games are having to be
postponed but it also comes as the
health secretary confirmed that more
than half of the adult population who
are eligible for boosters have received
their booster vaccines now
salia in charleston southeast london
thank you
well let's take a look at those
record-breaking covert 19 numbers across
the uk there have been 93 045 new cases
of covert 19 recorded in the latest
24-hour period
another 111 deaths have been reported
within 28 days of a positive test and
that brings the total number of deaths
in the uk to 147 048.
32
677 people received their first dose of
a vaccine while 42
497 had their second dose now that means
that more than 46.9
million people have now received their
second dose
and another daily record 860
306 people received their booster or
third vaccine in the past 24-hour period
26.3 million people have now had their
booster or third jab that's half of all
adults in the uk
well that's the picture here in the uk
but the omicron variant is also causing
increasing concern across europe
france has announced a raft of new
measures including a ban on fireworks
and official public parties this new
year's eve and reducing the time between
a second and booster jab to four months
the country's health pass will also
become a vaccine passport meaning people
will now have to be fully vaccinated to
get into restaurants museums and
sporting events
all that was announced just hours before
new travel restrictions came into force
banning travelled to and from the uk
without compelling reasons
if we've already recorded several
hundred cases of omicron in france we
think this variant will spread very
quickly and will become the dominant
strain from the beginning of 2022 as it
already is in the united kingdom
that's why we've decided to apply new
controls and restrictions on people
arriving on french soil from the ukraine
meanwhile ireland's prime minister mijo
martin has warned that vaccines alone
will not be enough to get through the
omicron wave as he announced new
measures
from sunday until the end of january
there will be an 8 pm curfew for
restaurants bars and all indoor sports
and events while wedding receptions will
be limited to 100 guests
in the netherlands the partial lockdown
that's been in place since november was
recently extended until mid-january
local media reports say the dutch
government's health experts are advising
a full lockdown to slow the spread of
omicron
a decision on that is expected later
today and in denmark all cinemas
theaters and museums must close from
sunday
face coverings are also already
compulsory in shops and on public
transport but that will now be extended
to schools and places of worship
and some of the danish queens golden
jubilee celebrations are even being
postponed they were due to take place in
january
over to the u.s now and gillen maxwell
has told the judge at her sex
trafficking trial that she will not
testify in her own defense
her legal team rested its case after two
days of presenting evidence in new york
its thought of verdict could be reached
as early as next week skye's mother
kellner has this report
these are nervous times for glenn
maxwell's siblings kevin and isabel in
the next week a jury will likely decide
whether their younger sister will spend
the rest of her life in
prison gulen maxwell has listened
intently as her life has been dissected
for the past three weeks her alleged
crimes laid bare finally it was her turn
to address the court she was calm and
assured but it was brief
she said your honor the government has
not proven its case beyond reasonable
doubt so there is no need for me to
testify
the defense rested its case after just
one and a half days far sooner than
expected
eva do you regret your friendship with
jeffrey epstein
they had called billionaire dr eva dubin
a longtime friend and defender of
jeffrey epstein he was godfather to her
three children she was asked were you
and mr dubin comfortable with the
relationship between mr epstein and your
children yes we were she responded they
called him uncle f
did you observe any inappropriate
behaviour between mr epstein
and teenage girls she was asked i did
not she responded
but crucially under cross-examination dr
dubin admitted she was struggling with
her memory recently
and couldn't recall events from a long
time ago
the defence also lost key legal
arguments over the admission of a number
of witnesses
when they return for closing arguments
on monday maxwell's expensively
assembled team of lawyers will hope for
a more convincing performance martha
kellner sky news new york
a sky news has gained exclusive access
to the smuggling middlemen responsible
for organizing the journeys of ten of
the people who died in the channel last
month
the agent based in iraqi kurdistan acts
as an intermediary between the families
of people desperate to reach the uk
and the smugglers profiting off them
or many migrants come from war-torn
countries like syria afghanistan yemen
and iraq
others are fleeing economic failure in
places like iran and parts of africa
while the key routes are via the western
mediterranean from morocco into spain
through tunisia and libya up in sumatra
and italy
by the eastern mediterranean through
turkey and greece
or increasingly via belarus and into
eastern europe
well that's the favored route for many
from iraq which was home to several of
those who died three weeks ago
our middle east correspondent alistair
bunker reports from iraqi kurdistan
we've been given permission to meet a
travel agent from a kurdish town in the
mountains of northern iraq
he is one of the money middlemen in the
global smuggling network
they mostly work from small offices in
towns around the middle east trusted by
the smugglers and by the migrants and
their families
they rarely ever appear on camera
foreign
the travel agents are integral to the
whole smuggling process this agent
helped 10 of the 31 people who drowned
in the english channel last month he
still holds their money but it will
eventually go back to the families
how do you feel
about the deaths
of so many people who came from this
district
telephone
business seems to be non-stop the agent
is constantly on the phone when we are
there passing on instructions to the
families and phoning smugglers
[Music]
foreign
[Laughter]
[Music]
a young man comes into the office just
as we are about to leave his sister is
in northern france and she is trying to
reach britain how do you feel about it
how do you feel
uh
about your sister taking that trip
across the channel after after what
happened last month
[Music]
[Music]
or just for tonight's crossing
for tonight just for tonight's crossing
show
so 2 500 pounds to travel across the
english channel tonight
if you remove these travel agents from
the chain the smuggling wouldn't stop
instead the smugglers would be more
likely to rip off the families
it might be illegal but just look at his
car
it's made him a rich man aleister bunker
sky news
in northern iraq
so the weather then what's that got in
store for us let's get all the details
now
[Music]
look forward to brighter skies
the weather sponsored by qatar airways
well conditions will remain very quiet
over the weekend that's a great news but
we do have some dense fog patches in
eastern parts leading to travel issues
and the zone from yorkshire through to
east anglia taking in the midlands will
be worst affected with visibility less
than 100 meters in places where fog will
be reluctant to clear elsewhere there
will be further patches of mist and fog
along with low cloud which will affect
much of england and wales
the weather sponsored by qatar airways
a real or fake that's often the big
question when it comes to buying a
christmas tree up to eight million real
christmas trees are sold in the uk each
year or a staggering amount
but each one needs around four thousand
liters of water to grow but instead of
buying a tree or you can rent one and
have it delivered taken away and
replanted skies dan whitehead has this
report
there is a tree
this christmas it's not just santa that
two-year-old edward is waiting for
concerned about the environment his
grandparents have opted for a different
type of christmas tree
delivered in december picked up again in
january and then replanted the family
hope their rented christmas tree will be
more friendly for the environment
because i see the same tree year on year
and i can watch it grow and when edward
comes in it'll get bigger and edward
will get bigger and it's just
it was just like bringing part of the
family for kiosks really to something
that has some meaning and it can you
know environmentally friendly is great
because we know we're not throwing
anything away eco elf is the brainchild
of calamo driscoll i was just fed up of
throwing away christmas trees me and my
wife we've always loved getting a real
tree even from when i was a child you
know and the smell was great
but taking it down to the
council-organized tip in the car park
around the corner and seeing a massive
pile of cut trees was just a shame
really each christmas up to eight
million real trees are sold in the uk
there is of course no shortage of
artificial options
for many they are the centerpiece of
christmas but as we're all more
conscious of our carbon footprint just
which are better for the environment
real
or fake
according to the carbon trust a six and
a half foot artificial tree equates to
around 40 kilograms of co2 when
considering manufacturing metal plastic
packaging and transport
a real fertilized tree is a tenth of
that at around four kilograms of co2
however certain types of artificial
trees can have a lower overall carbon
footprint if used for at least seven
years although artificial might be
better long term a real tree can have
other environmental benefits
if your tree at its end of life if it's
collected by a local authority and then
you know
burnt for energy or or used um as wood
chipping or as composting then those
have really positive benefits as well so
in the composting or chipping example
obviously it helps with you know soil
quality improvements and that's really
important real or fake it remains a
divisive issue like to have a real tree
together it seems a bit lazy to have um
artificial one how long have you had
your fake tree
oh
it's about 30 to 35 years old has it
still got some needles it's yes it has
so we've got needles still got the
fairy on the top
dan whitehead sky news
now businesses up and down the country
have borne the bronze of the coronavirus
pandemic and the latest outbreak of the
omicron variants has threatened to cause
yet more misery over christmas well with
me now is hairdresser joe mills whose
salon has been experiencing
cancellations and also staff isolation
so joe good morning to you thanks for
your time there is a double whammy there
for you isn't it with the staff and also
cancellations how many cancellations
have you had
um good morning vanessa thanks for
having me on um
for us as a business we're based in
central illinois we have three stores
compared to a normal pre-pandemic
christmas we're down at least 50 and
what we've noticed since the plan b
introduction is that there has been you
know widespread cancellations of clients
either working from home and not coming
into town or because they're testing
positive or they don't want to risk the
chance of coming into you know into
contact with some of them with it on top
of that we've had a couple of staff
isolations we've had to do but i think
across the industry it's it's been a
very brutal
end to the year
you know 75 of salons are talking about
um mass cancellations and a real drop in
business
um so how much of your business then do
you normally make around this time of
year and i know that this is peak season
for businesses like yours
so i think for hairdressing barbering
and beauty i think we
you know december really is our month
and that carries you through january and
february you know the issue is that if
you
on you know aren't making that extra
revenue the start of you know 2022 for
us is you know becomes more more
perilous i guess and equally with the
the vagueness of what we're doing and
where we're going and the lack of proper
communication has a real direct impact
on
future planning for your business
and for you i mean in terms of
percentage-wise for example you know
what are you looking at in terms of the
hits that you've taken fifty percent
oh it's it's enormous you know you know
if you think about you know for us
personally
you know we're based in soho and central
london and and you know since the plan b
restrictions kicked in
you know it it has had a marked impact
on all small businesses not just just my
industry you know and i understand you
know how the impact has impact the
impact has had on on hospitality but
there are lots of other other industries
including ours that have don't get the
kind of attention
um of what you know what the impact is
having on us as well
absolutely and what kind of support
would you like to get from the
government because a chancellor has cut
short his business trip to the us are
you hopeful of any financial supports at
all i think
i think it's more historical i think
it's more over the whole period of the
pandemic rather than a short-term fix
you know i think hmrc
really need to reconsider you know the
situation that a lot of us are in
because you know
a lot of a lot of small business carries
hmrc debt is is a part of business it's
not ideal you know whether that could be
capitalized into loans or whether you
had um more support or and even a clear
understanding if we knew that you know
there's talk every day now that you know
potential restrictions after christmas
or in january or you know all we need is
the communications we can plan and as a
small business owner you know you're
responsible not only for your your your
staff and their mental well-being but
also your clients as well so you do
carry quite a burden and and i think
that it's just clarity and i don't think
that
um
i don't think that we've had any
targeted funding or support specifically
for our industry as other industries
have
and um you know i think rishi you know
if he could at least have a broader
spectrum approach to you know what
support we need um and just clarity
joe thank you very much indeed there's
joe mills there speaking to us thanks
for your time thank you very much thank
you well with us now to review the
papers are dawn neesom former editor of
the daily star along with broadcaster
and journalist vidisha good morning to
you both it's great to see you a little
change there bedisha i like it
do you know if you're going to come on
sky news just show up do you know what i
mean i like it
it's good to have you um badisha let me
kick off with um the case of simon case
and the parties
well you make it sound like the latest
harry potter film
simon case and the forbidden parties but
actually it's not very funny at all
because a lot of people are extremely
outraged so simon case despite his john
le carre-like name is a very top civil
servant who had been tasked until
recently with leading an inquiry into
mps in government who were breaking the
rules this time last year against having
parties have having gatherings we were
supposed to be in lockdown in isolation
being very careful
you know as well as i do that there were
many families all over the country who
just to follow the rules they wouldn't
see their own parents their own
grandkids their own in-laws
so that we could get these case numbers
down now it turns out that uh the
naughty mr case can't investigate this
case because he too is guilty
potentially allegedly of the very things
that he is investigating so
it transpires that there was a party
slash meeting
sounds totally dreadful gathering in his
own offices and just to make you not
miss parties at all 15 people from his
office were invited to a christmas
gathering an email went out with the
christmas party christmas quiz written
in the subject heading
huge surprise not everyone turned up for
this thrilling sounding party encounter
he himself allegedly did not attend the
scintillating quiz he merely walked
through it stone faced on the way to his
own office um the problem is that when
you behave like this as a government you
lose the trust of the nation this isn't
really about parties and about this guy
this is about
accountability it's about taking
responsibility and it's about practicing
what you preach well dawn isn't enough
then to say listen i wasn't at the party
i wasn't there it wasn't me but actually
as badish was saying you have to look at
accountability leadership too
of course you do and the problem we've
all got now vanessa is that we have been
told well their version of the truth
let's put it that way about what they
were doing and what they expected us to
do last christmas so i think the vast
majority of us now i mean myself
included just go
i i just can't take your advice
seriously anymore i mean
it's it's confusing at the best of times
but it's like when you're when you're
ignoring all your own rules how on earth
do you expect people to follow the rules
you are setting across and you know
there have been several polls over the
last couple of days vanessa with people
going they're not doing it they don't
care
what the government say anymore
it's like we are not following your
rules we are going to do what we want
this christmas and you honestly you know
who can blame them i mean this is where
we are now
and um
dawn um staying with you know the theme
around coronavirus then there's a slight
change in gear here um why are there
claims that
java's claims of the 200 000 daily cases
is no longer valid what's going on here
this is really interesting this was our
um acclaim sadly
made on monday and it was modelling and
it was used to
our
basically convinced the the tory rebels
as we know that a lot of them voted
against vaccine passports and new
regulations coming in it was used to
convince them that we did need stricter
um
regulations on our life
now
and there was a new report that was sort
of quietly
put out on first
saying that this actually these figures
no longer apply and you should not be
using them anymore it's basically you
know the uk health and security agency
consistently warned on immigration
doubling every 1.9 days but mythology
methodology has
said that this is wrong now and we
should drop this modeling so it's
actually in theory good news and you
know there's the thing we with all the
statistics as we said in in part one of
our newspaper review this morning the
thing with all these statistics is you
read um it's it's all very very
confusing but the good news i think with
this vanessa is the
the um the information coming from south
africa is that the case fatality rate
has plummeted the death rate for over
80s is around 20
compared to 50 for the delta and for 70
79 year olds it's down to 10
and these are the latest stats coming
out of south africa so in theory we it
is good news and we really shouldn't be
panicking too much
well we'll take any hint of good news
that we can get um let me um come to you
um there um badisha because
we're stepping away from covert right
now and the twist and strictly um
showdown aj um a doodoo who's supposed
to be in the final may not actually be
able to do it because she's
you know she's had some injury hasn't
she now this is a program that my
parents are obsessed with well more like
my mom and my dad has no choice but you
know it's not something i usually watch
i'll be honest with you but i've my
interest has peaked because of aj what a
what is what a sad case right now
well is it sad you said we're stepping
away from covid let's just say we're fox
stepping away from covert because even
though it's it's hard
it's hard to believe that other channels
do exist uh when we live in the
wonderful world of sky news but there is
a little thing called strictly come
dancing it's on tonight the finals are
on tonight and yes aj has said that
she's gonna have to step away because of
injury and we know that we've lost other
dancers because they're being voted out
and all sorts of uh coveted ailments and
other things have bedeviled the sparkly
dancing moving music and drama show and
i'm wondering just exactly what kind of
love affairs are happening behind the
scenes love is wonderful so in these
dark times who's to begrudge any of it
but it means the final is going to be
interesting just in terms of diversity
and equality because
we're either going to have the first
really fabulous deaf contestant which is
rose island ellis or we're going to have
the first same-sex couple which is john
and johannes now they're going to be
facing off against each other but it's a
great win in the sense that whoever wins
is going to be a pioneer on this massive
primetime telly show they're going to be
a front runner for anyone who watched
strictly for all the other dozens of
seasons and felt like they weren't
represented
you know are you telling me that uh gay
guys don't like a dance you telling me
that deaf people don't like music i
don't think that's true absolutely
absolutely and i do hope also that aj
does recover um quickly and with your
change of outfits as well bedisha you
can definitely waltz your way there
dawn she could and you too actually as
well so dawn have you been following up
with uh with strictly and aj's injury
i yeah i have and i feel desperately
sorry for anything all the hard work
that's gone into the training and it's
not just what we get to see on our
screens obviously but you know they
prepare beforehand the immense amount of
training that goes on during the week um
it's incredibly hard work and you know
what i mean i'm a secret fan as well i
haven't watched it religiously this
series i must have met um obviously
because i'm watching sky news a lot but
it's it's the sparkles it's the fun it's
the joy
and at this time of year i just think
it's so important that we we do
turn off the white noise of of kobe and
politics and and just actually try to
have a bit of fun and you know the
sparkles it's just lovely i mean i love
christmas i mean you've got a long way
to ruin it for me and and all the
parties at number 10 and white were
having well
well with your christmas then dawn you
may have to go for a dry christmas
basically because of cracking we're you
know um festive dry run as drinkers turn
to low alcohol alternatives after the
year we've had
yeah right vanessa um okay i can tell
you it's really definitely not happening
in my world and i've got a crate of
champagne for christmas being delivered
in an hour or so um but yeah this is in
the guardian and it's brits appears to
be dreaming of a dry christmas a
supermarket report soaring sounds of low
alcohol and non-alcoholic drinks
sainsbury said that sales of low alcohol
products have soared by 91 compared to
last december i mean hello people
how are you doing this i mean look fair
play if you are and lots of people are
doing it for health reasons and
obviously there are but you know the
addiction thing aside obviously there's
a serious issue for this and we've got
dry january coming up which i might be
taking part in yeah but i mean after the
year we've had fast christmas exactly
how is anybody going to get through it
without glass of champagne dawn i'll
come to you very quickly vedic are you
having a dry christmas very quickly
no i'm just like dawn i've got the
shanks waiting downstairs we'll see you
guys in an hour i'll see you in a few
minutes
[Music]